[Music]
[Applause]
we were just talking during the break i
don't know why nick saban would open
this up i know that it was a home game
in birmingham with local businessmen and
you you know they're going to react to
you they're going to be on your side and
you know it felt like an oh woe is me
how are we going to compete here
and he talked about he wanted parody
well this is a good way to get parody if
you let people of these other schools
and boosters pay money to these players
now you're seeing tweets from former
players talking about how players got
paid
what they got paid
we're just opening the door here i mean
they've been paid it's just how did you
pay them how did you get around the ncaa
when the ncaa actually used to be the
ncaa now
this is a loophole that texas a m took
advantage of
i don't know what you do to close it
that's why we bring in pat 40. covers
the sport for sports illustrated
um let me play the nick saban clip the
first one here pat then i'll get your
reaction to it
we were second in recruiting last year a
m was first a m bought every player on
their team made a deal for name image
and like all right we didn't buy one
player all right but i don't know if
we're going to be able to sustain that
in the future because more and more
people are doing it
what does he mean what is he what's the
message he wants out there
well i i think two things the operative
phrase is there we were sad
nick saban doesn't like being second he
was beaten and recruiting that's what
this basically boils down to i think
it's more of that than a matter of
principle here
he's a competitive guy and saw somebody
take advantage of the new landscape uh
to to
his own detriment now what his the
second part of the equation there and
he's a smart calculating guy
might be a message to the alabama
boosters hey i know we got to step it up
here
you know our nil efforts are lacking
compared to others and i think alabama
has been a little more slow into that
space perhaps thinking we don't need to
we're alabama we're still going to get
guys but when you finish second in
recruiting in your nick saban it takes
on a greater sense of urgency
is nick saban saying that they have
never paid a player
to go to alabama like i want sec media
day to be lie detector test
everybody sits down let's just talk
about your recruiting
how do you think these coaches would do
we sec spring meetings start in i think
12 days and one of the first items of
business is a football coaches meeting
so i'd love to be in there to see jimbo
and uh and nick hash that one out
uh but yeah i mean look that
i think we all know the underground
economy was humming along for decades
players were getting paid we just didn't
know who and how much now we have a
better idea of what the compensation
levels are like above board and yeah if
if you had the best recruiting classes
forever
it stands to reason that those players
were getting paid now alabama obviously
has the ultimate uh recruiting incentive
which is the best pipeline to the nfl
but that's not all i mean let's i think
be realistic about where players were
going and why they were making some
school choices but also if i'm a player
coming out of college and alabama
recruits me
chances are i won't start right away
and i could go someplace else
get name image and likeness money let's
say i go to miami or pittsburgh or
a m you know throw out any of these
schools i could go get paid play for two
years put myself back on the market and
then maybe tran nobody has a better
transfer portal
results than alabama does i mean they
got three players i think this year that
will play in the nfl through transfer
portal so they're i could do that and
then get paid when i get there if if i'm
believing what nick saban is saying we
don't entice you out of high school
sure i mean like yeah you could you
could certainly play the system that way
there's no doubt about it that you can
get paid on the front end and then if
alabama is going to continue to do
things this way of well when you become
a starter you become a star then you'll
start to see the benefits yeah you can
get it both ways you could get it
somewhere else that's going to pay you
to come in to sign a letter of intent
and show up and then you could transfer
to alabama if you're good enough uh and
get paid there and then have that
pipeline to the nfl so sure i mean we're
seeing players that are working the
system i i'm impressed really by some of
the ways players who now are having
agents uh are are exploiting what the
system is now allowing them to get
if you're jimbo fisher
what's your reaction today
well it's interesting because he's
already reacted a couple of times since
people started taking shots at their
number one recruiting class and you know
one of the things was you know if you've
been to our campus have you been to a
game here if you got seen the education
in the 12th man in the aggie network
it's like you know
college station is 90 minutes from
anywhere surrounded by tumbleweeds
bathed in everything's beige i i don't
know whether you're getting guys from
philadelphia and scottsdale arizona that
are in this class based on those things
so
it's just funny to me that coaches even
now that they're allowed to say yes we
are offering incentives to these players
they can't bring themselves to say it
they're so accustomed to no no they're
coming here because we work hard and
because we're going to develop them it's
just kind of funny so we'll probably get
another round of that from jimbo here
yeah if i'm a coach i just go yeah
we pay our players we pay them really
really well come on in we're open for
business yes paulie uh a m is called
media availability with coach jimbo
fisher at 11 a.m eastern today oh just
came in oh here we go
okay here is nick saban calling out dion
sanders and jackson state
the rules just like nate said we have a
rule right now that says you cannot use
name image likeness to entice a player
to come to your school
hell read about it in the paper
i mean jackson state paid a guy a
million dollars last year that was a
really good division one player to come
to school it was in the paper and they
bragged about it nobody did anything
about it okay
why bring dion into this
i thought they were buddies in the
affleck commercial right i know the next
photo or next commercial shoot's gonna
be a little little tense but uh
yeah that i don't know that's
interesting other than i mean i do think
there's an element of nick saban like
i'm 70 years old and i can say whatever
the heck i want i don't know i think
there's something to that
now the one he's he's short on on
substance here he's short on facts and
figures like are we sure that that he
was paid a million dollars i don't know
these are fairly bold statements i think
that was surely assumed in a lot of
areas but nick saban went there with a
degree of specificity that uh that could
have some blowback as you said jimbo is
going to talk here in i guess about a
half hour and and dion on twitter has
promised that he will address the lies
by coach saban
you lose the national championship to
georgia you lose the recruiting class
you know to texas a m i mean it's not
the end of the world for alabama
nick wants parody
he said that he's hoping for parody
he's the reason why they we haven't had
parody in college football how is he
going to
provide parody for college football
yeah no i mean obviously yes the biggest
reason we don't have parody today is
because nick saban has dominated the
sport for 13 years now and they'll be
number one to start this year they
should win it again this year uh i think
now the parody comments now start to
make a little more sense to me
in that i think he's thinking
parody in terms of we're all
offering things under the same guys
basically of
we can we we can offer whatever we want
but not until you get to college
parody that sort of parody i think was
as opposed to a recruiting parody where
hey we're going to offer you 800 000 to
sign right now whereas this other school
is not i think that's what he wants is
more of an even application of what nil
is supposed to be that that's my guess
my interpretation of what he was saying
there because at the time it made no
sense what he was talking but also the
enticement we're talking to pat 40 from
sports illustrated the enticement i i
can entice you i don't have to give you
something up front but you do know wink
wink if you go to alabama that we will
give we will take care of you so it's
semantics to me maybe it's not up front
maybe it's not out you know on a
billboard
but when you get here we're going to
take care of you
i mean these are grown-ups who are
embarrassing themselves with the way
they act and what they say and how they
say it
it feels like you know the the players
the athletes or the grown-ups they're
like uh all right you guys created this
uh we're gonna take advantage of it
we're gonna outsmart you at your own
game
yeah no i i agree i mean it is a very
thin line between
what you can what's being offered up
front and what you will inevitably get i
mean bryce young had a podcast
uh before he had started a game at
alabama and nick saban said last summer
before he had started a game that he was
getting about seven figures so
you know it's not like you can't get
paid at alabama if you go there uh so
i agree that what this basically i think
boils down to
nobody can get their arms around exactly
what nil
should be
supposed to be what we want it to be and
if there's just going to be a lot of
infighting and arguing about it until we
come up with a solution and frankly i
don't know what the solution is i mean
the ncaa can't enforce its own rules
so if you're sitting around waiting for
them to create a level playing field
good luck
can you create your own rules in your
own conference let's say the sec says we
have our own rules here
or the pac-12 or the big ten like can
you just kind of
secede from the ncaa and say we're going
to govern our own league and this is
what we're going to allow or not allow
we're heading to that no doubt the the
ncaa transformation committee which has
been meeting for months i think they
have an august 1st deadline to produce
their recommendations and i think that's
going to be one of the recommendations
is basically conferences can almost
uh kind of govern themselves and part of
that will be what are the rules what's
the rules compliance now
rules enforcement among conferences well
they tried that before in the old days
people had conferences tried to be their
own rule enforcers it didn't work nobody
really wanted that in their best
interests we don't nobody the sec does
not want to have somebody turn in
alabama and say alabama's cheating and
saying oh we better go bust alabama they
don't want that
i mean so you know i i don't think it'll
be very effective but i think it'll
get some of the onus off of an
ineffective ncaa and start handing
things out to the individual leagues to
do what they want it's the gift that
keeps on giving thank you pat great to
talk to you
my pleasure dan thank you that's pat
forty from sports illustrated